jede minute werden auf youtube 400
stunden videomaterial hochgeladen
103 millionen spam mails landen täglich
in unserem postfächern und auf twitter
werden rund 500 millionen tweets
versendet das sind 6000 tweets pro
sekunde
kein menschenleben reicht aus um das
alles zu verarbeiten
im dauerfeuer an geschichten bildern und
verführerischen angeboten fühlt sich
manch einer überfordert es herrscht
information overload doch wie kommt die
schiere masse von informationen
überhaupt zustande
durch die schnelle taktung in der neue
informationen hergestellt werden steigt
der druck auf alle selbst neue inhalte
zu produzieren zeitung etwa
aktualisieren ihre seiten im stundentakt
etwas weltweit zu publizieren ist leicht
geworden
jeder kann ein video drehen und
hochladen außerdem nehmen die
nachrichtenkanäle ständig zu zu viele
informationen zu viele wahlmöglichkeiten
darauf reagieren wir auf zwei
verschiedene arten zum einen mit
dauernder wachsamkeit und hyper
sensibilität
man hält es ohne ständig neuen input gar
nicht mehr mit sich selbst aus der
stress level steigt und damit die angst
etwas wichtiges zu übersehen oder etwas
interessantes zu verpassen
andere stumpfen ab interessieren sich
für nichts mehr über lassen sich der
flut der bunten bilder
[Musik]
unter stress werden wir einerseits
vergesslicher und unkonzentrierte was
mir besonders sorge macht ist dass wir
anfang stärker zu polarisieren
das heißt wir bescheiden mehr in schwarz
weiß wir nehmen situationen schneller
als bedrohlich war das heißt durch die
überforderung die entsteht fangen
menschen auch an in diesem modus zu
kommen wo die schnelle angreifen
schneller streiten
dr jan kalbitzer ist facharzt für
psychiatrie und psychotherapie erforscht
haben zentrum für internet und seelische
gesundheit der charité berlin
menschen wollen wissen was in der welt
los ist und durch diesen ständigen
nachrichten des ständigen alarmismus mit
dem nachrichten verstärkt sich in der
angst der menschen vor dem internet oder
auch vor der welt da draußen das ist
schon das auf einer virtuellen realität
leben wir gehen durch eine wahnsinns
sichere stadt und haben dauernd angst
und überflutet werden und gefährlichen
nachrichten im internet gibt es zu jeder
meinung eine gegenmeinung manchmal ist
es fast unmöglich fakten von fake news
zu unterscheiden und weit und breit
niemand der das chaos für uns
durchschaubarer machen kann
die suchmaschinen den wir uns
anvertrauen suchen uns schließlich nicht
die besten sollen die am besten
bezahlten informationen heraus das ist
ein großes problem wenn wir alles was im
internet ist über geld regulieren das
darf nicht mehr stattfinden wir müssen
als gesellschaft viel stärker der
eingreifen politische braucht jeder
einzelne das internet verändert unser
gehirn auch strukturell
es gibt forschungsergebnisse die darauf
hindeuten dass das tägliche computer
multitasking zu einer schlechteren
verschaltung im frontalen kortex führt
gleichzeitig ist zb der teil des
sensomotorischen kortex der zuständig
ist für die daumen bewegung bei den
heute 15 jährigen doppelt so groß wie
bei ihren eltern
man kann also nicht einfach behaupten
das internet würde uns dümmer machen als
menschen angefangen haben im gegensatz
zu den affen den daumen der hand
gegenüber zu stellen werkzeuge zu
benutzen dass unser gehirn auch komplett
verändert in seiner struktur weil man
sind wir viel aufrechten gang in die
hand besser nutzen zu können
das ändert sich permanenten das muss es
auch es muss sich ja neuen
umweltförderungen anpassen
die frage ist also viel eher wie wir
wissen besser für uns organisieren
können ob man sich nun selbst eine
informations diät verordnet oder
gemeinsam mit freunden und familie
überlegt wie man stressfreier durchs
internet kommt medienkompetenz brauchen
heute alle